spot head on over to our website at
spacex.com
rideshare we are just
under five minutes to lift off falcon 9
is now moving into the final stages
of the countdown uh any moment now the
strong back will begin to open up its
clamp
once open they will retract away from
the rocket to its pre-launch position
about two degrees away from falcon 9 and
as falcon 9 lifts off
hydraulic arms will pull the strong back
farther away
to make sure that it is clear during
liftoff
strongback retract has started so there
was a call out for strong back retract
you can see the clamp arms just under
fairing start to open up
the strongback is part of the transport
erector also called the
te again its job is to roll falcon 9 out
to the launch pad
raise it to a vertical launch position
about power fluids and communication to
both the rocket
and satellite
and you can start to hear some of the
hissing and popping and that is pressure
venting from the rocket
and the plumbing in the transporter
erector
[Applause]
at this stage the strongback should be
uh reclined to its pre-launch position
two degrees away from falcon 9. the
vehicle remains in good health the first
and second stages are almost done
fueling gaseous oxygen is also vented to
the base of falcon 9 that is the chillin
of the merlin engine turbo pumps about a
minute before liftoff you will hear the
announcement that falcon 9
is in startup which means that the
rockets own internal computers are now
autonomously controlling the launch
countdown
[Music]
and just to check quicken on weather
we're still green
the range is standing by to support
today's mission as a reminder if we
don't launch today we do have a backup
opportunity tomorrow at the same time
for those that are just tuning in on
screen is a live view of falcon 9
at space launch complex 40 off the coast
of florida we are in the middle of the
transporter 2 mission this is spacex's
second
dedicated smallsat rideshare mission
[Music]
stage two locks load complete
and there was a call up for second stage
locks loading complete that is the last
of propellant load falcon 9 is now fully
fueled
and ready to lift off in about a minute
and 40 seconds
this is the eighth time that this
booster will be flying today
and a bit later on we'll also be
attempting to recover it for the eighth
time
back at landing zone one
so you can start to see some white
clouds forming around falcon 9.
that is normal and expected at this
stage in the countdown
that is cold dense liquid oxygen meeting
the
warmer ambient air of florida and
starting to condense
and form those white clouds that you see
on screen
[Music]
[Music]
in startup and this means that the first
and second phases are beginning
to pressurize for launch
we're just about 20 seconds away from
liftoff
ld this is our stand countdown ranges no
go repeat range is no go
hold hold hold
and we did hear the call to hold
give us a second we're going to check in
with the teams and see if we can get
some more information for you
the countdown hold due to a foul burns
so we did have a hold it looks like the
range was a no-go
there might have been an airplane in the
area we do have a backup opportunity
tomorrow but for today that's going to
do it for us
hopefully you'll join us tomorrow for
the next launch attempt of transporter
[Music]
2.